hi there steve kaufman uh founder of
link here and uh i'm going to talk to
you about the third of my secrets to
successful language learning
uh the first one was to spend the time
every day and for as long as it takes
the second
secret was to do things that you like to
do in language learning and that will
ensure your success and ensure that you
stay with it
the third
secret is to
notice
what is happening in the language this
is extremely
important
now how do you develop the ability to
notice
there are a number of things that you
need to do first of all i would like to
stress that the ability to notice is
probably the largest difference
or the most significant difference
between people who are good at language
learning and people who are not good at
language learning so it's very important
to develop the ability to notice now the
first thing you need to do
is to
make sure you get a lot of exposure to
the language
through
listening reading or if you prefer
watching videos but somehow you have to
get a lot of the language into you
because you can't notice things that you
haven't already experienced
it's a bit like the
saying you can only learn what you
already know
it sounds a bit contradictory but
you can't notice until you've actually
consciously and subconsciously
experienced something so
hopefully you are
spending a lot of time
uh
gaining that exposure to the language
now how do you start noticing
there are a number of things that can
help you notice first of all you have to
want to notice so if i'm reading i'll
often underline certain
expressions or words if i'm reading at
link i will save words and phrases to my
personal database just the act of saving
them helps me notice now when i review
these in flashcards
that again helps me notice it's not that
it's not because i review them in
flashcards that i'm going to remember
them i won't necessarily remember them
some words i'll remember some i won't
but it's all slowly building up this
ability to notice
if i'm corrected
it may help me notice it may not but it
certainly won't necessarily correct me
maybe an explanation from a teacher or
an explanation in a grammar book will
help me notice and that's why i very
often uh review grammar books very
quickly
not again with the intention
or the hope that i'll remember a
particular rule or a particular verb
ending but because it's just that
process that continuous cumulative
process of getting me to notice certain
things and once i notice something
let's say it was a correction in my
writing and then i look for it when i'm
reading or when i hear the language and
all of a sudden i start to notice these
things everywhere and as we notice
things in the language they become a
part of us and pretty soon because we've
noticed it here and notice that there
suddenly automatically we start using
these words uh and phrases or patterns
of the language uh more correctly now
the same is true with pronunciation you
can't pronounce what you can't hear so
you have to pay attention to how the the
language is pronounced and it's not just
the individual sounds you need to pay
attention to it's the intonation and
sometimes it can be very useful to
listen and imitate because that's
helping you to notice so
whether it be pronunciation or correct
usage it's or the accumulation of words
and phrases it's very important to to
hone that ability to notice and it
starts with a desire to notice the
conscious determination will
to say i'm going to try to notice the
language and then you can train yourself
through these various activities
so that's the third hint learn to notice
the language and you'll become
an efficient and successful language
learner thank you